to zoom back out
we've been talking about the genetic
origins of diseases but i think it's
fascinating to
talk about what are the most important
diseases to understand
and especially as it connects to the
things that you're working on
so it's very difficult to think about
important diseases to understand there's
many metrics of importance
one is lifestyle impact i mean if you
look at kovid the impact on lifestyle
has been enormous
so understanding kovid is important
because
it has impacted the well-being in terms
of
ability to have a job ability to have an
apartment ability to go to work
ability to have a mental circle of
support
and all of that for you know millions of
americans like
huge huge impact so that's one aspect of
importance so basically mental disorders
alzheimer's has a huge importance in the
well-being of americans whether or not
it die
it kills someone for many many years it
has a huge impact
so the first measure of importance is
just well-being
impact on the quality of life impact on
the quality of life absolutely
the second metric which is much easier
to quantify is deaths
what is the number one killer the number
one killer
is actually heart disease it is actually
killing
650 000 americans per year
number two is cancer with 600 000
americans
number three far far down the list is
accidents
every single accident combined so
basically you you know you read the news
accidents like you know there was a huge
car crash all over the news
but the number of deaths number three by
far
167 thousand lower respiratory disease
so that's
asthma not being able to breathe and so
forth 160 000
alzheimer's number four number five with
120 000
and then stroke brain aneurysms and so
forth that's 147 000
diabetes and metabolic disorders etc
that's 85 000.
the flu is 60 000 suicide
50 000 and then overdose et cetera
you know goes further down the list so
of course kovit has creeped up to be the
number three killer
this year with you know more than
hundred thousand americans
and counting um and
you know but but if you think about sort
of what do we
use what are the most important diseases
you have to understand both
the quality of life and the sheer number
of deaths
and just numbers of years lost if you
wish
you